Bêtement...
Je me mets à te chercher dans le lit.
Je vois que tu n'es plus ici.
Bêtement...
J'oublie les "elletement".
Je garde tes vêtements.
Tout ça, bêtement !
C'est dur...
D'écouter tous mes potes qui me disent...
Que je devrais t'oublier...
A chaque fois que j'essaye...
Mais je commence à douter en mes capacités à le faire.
Je te vois partout...
Et à chaque fois, je crois que c'est toi !
Et je me rends compte que ce n'est pas toi !
Je te vois partout...
Puis à chaque fois, je crois que c'est toi !
Mais je me rends compte que ce n'est pas toi !
Anis !
C'est moi.
C'est Farah.
Je te cherche en vain.
Vais-je te voir enfin ?
Je suis là, hein ?
Je te cherche sans arrêt.
Mais je ne peux pas te trouver !
Je suis là !
Tu n'es pas là.
Non mais tu te fous de ma gueule, là ?
Putain ! Mais tu m'as tout pris, déjà. Tu veux me prendre ça aussi, c'est ça ?
Tu... Le refrain.
C'est dur d'écouter tous mes potes qui me disent...
Tiens,, chérie. Je t'ai pris un smoothie.
Merci. C'est gentil.
... té, en mes capacités à le faire.
C'est qui, lui ?
C'est mon ex, en fait.
Cool !
Ecouter tous mes potes qui me disent...
Que je devrais t'oublier...
Il était chanteur avant ?
Non, pas du tout.
Pas du tout.
Même... Même pas dans un groupe ? Un truc comme ça ?
Faut que j'essaye mais je commence à douter...
En mes capacités à le faire.
Il les connait les deux mecs qui sont avec lui, là ?
Quelqu'un peut appeler la police, s'il-vous-plaît ?
Et bien, j'ai pas l'impression, tu vois.
Mon corps est stylé.
T'as le seum.
Où es-tu ?
Dis-moi où es-tu.
Là, c'est toi qu'il appelle là, non ?
Dis-moi où es-tu !
Je lui ai dit que j'étais là, hein... Je...
Bon.
On y va ?
Wesh sans me connaître depuis j'ai fait de la taule...
J'essaye de pas promettre.
Toi, t'es tout sauf honnête.
Tu racontes des sornettes.
Ta meuf kiffe. Je le vois sur ses yeux, ses pommettes...
Il fait quoi, lui ?!
Un flot qui...
Parce que en... En garde à vue... En garde à vue personne m'a vu...
Tu m'as vu, m'as-tu vu ? M'as-tu vu ? Tu ne savais pas où j'étais.
Il pue sa mère !
Vous allez vous faire retourner...
Comme une crêpe.